اريد الشاب الاردني المختفي يكشفون العربي
تفاصيل جديده الامير هاريتهم زوجه ابيه
بتسريب معلومات خطيره للاعلام اعتقال
عصابه تساعد الطلب على الغش باختبارات
الثانويه بالكويت هذا الاخبار وغيرها
ننقلها لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
بعد نحوي ثلاثه اسابيع على اختفاء ابنه في
بريطانيا كشف والد الشاب الاردني احمد
دبور العربيه تفاصيل جديده في القضيه التي
اثار ضجه وتعاطفا واسعا في مواقع التواصل
نضال دبور لم يكن سعيدا خلال الفتره
الاخيره والسبب قد يكون نتيجه التعطر في
دراسه الجامعيه مشيرا الى ان العائله حجزت
لاحمد تذكره عوده الى الاردن يوم الثالث
والعشرين من ديسمبر الماضي لكنه اختفى
وقتها كما كشف دبور ان نجله لم يستخدم
البطاقه الائتمانيه بعد الثانيه والعشرين
من ديسمبر الى انه يسافر الى بريطانيا
للبحث عن مكان
قبل اطلاق الكتاب الجديد في الاسواق والذي
يحكي اسرار حياته خلف اسوار القصر اتهم
الامير هاري زوجه ابيه كامله باركر في
تسريب معلومات سريه
الاحد والاثنين اتهام افرادا من الاسره
الملكيه بالتعاون مع الشيطان او الصحافه
الصفراء الحصول على تغطيه الصحفيه
امام الجمهور البريطاني بعد علاقتها
الطويله مع والده هذا فيما افادتنا
المذكرات تتضمن تفاصيل معارك عائليه مريره
وايضا قرارها هاري وزوجته بالتخلي عن
ادوارهم الملكيه والانتقال الى كاليفورنيا
وائل الكويت هذه المره هتوافدت وسائل
الاعلام المحليه بين السلطات مكه اعتقال
اعضاء عصابه تساعد الطلبه على الغش في
اختبارات الثانويه
وهي مكونه من ثلاثه كويتيين موظفين بوزاره
التربيه والسوري يعمل مندوبا للمبيعات
مشيره الى انه يتقاضون نحو 490 دولار عن
كل ماده كما انهم يزودون الطلبه بسماعات
خاصه للغش وربطهام لتلقي اجابات الاسئله
يوم الاختبارات
بعد ان نحوي السنه على وفاته فتح السحر
الابراشي ارمله الاعلامي المصريه
فقط
لموقع القاهره 24 انا ساره
الى انها ذهبت لزياره قبره بعد الفجر
متخفيه
رفضت زيارتها للمقابر
وفي خبرنا الاخير ابتكر علماء الصينيون
محركات جديده لطائره مسيره سيساعد على
بقائها في الجو فتره طويله جدا صحيفه
سانتاين امورنا
علماء في جامعه نرجس صينيه للعلوم
التطبيقيه استخدمه اشعه ريزر فائقه الطاقه
في هذا المحرك الجديد وشيرين الى انهم
ابتكرونا نموذج يمكن تحويل الطاقه يمكن
تحويل الطاقه الشمسيه الى طاقه كهربائيه
ما يسمح بشحن الطائره المصريه
[موسيقى]